ME.
THEY HAVE A GAME IN
PHILADELPHIA ON TUESDAY.ASTER A
DEPRESSION. T
THERE IN THE RED. RED BY HYDRO.
>> Joe: SPARKS HAS FACED 22
DIFFERENT  GOALS OF ALL TIME AT
THE MOMENT.
TH.
HE GOT RIGHT.
JANSEN ON THE N ALLOWS A LANE  M
T.J.
OSHIE.
ON THE COVID
SNIVELY WITH A GIVE AND GO.  WI
DMITRY ORLOV AND FIVE ON
THE TEAM SHOULD NOT HAVE A SHOT
ON GOAL DURING THE MYEAR
FOR ALL OF US.
CONNOR McMICHAEL IN TH
NHL SPORTS WASHINGTON.
FIRE. KINGS 19-10.P BY SPARKS. .
IT EXPIRES IN SIX.
ONE CHANCE TO BLOCK IN THE
SECOND ONE HE LAST
NIGHT AND ANOTHER ONE TONIGHT.
GOOD TURNOVER BY THE>> Joe: E L
HE HAS BEEN BOUNCING AROUND.
HE GETS OPPORTUNITIES.
HE GETS GAMES HERE AND THERE
THAT I ON A FOOT RACE .
LARS ELLGO.
THAT WILL BE